[Music]
welcome to best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself
you can just watch this video or if you
want to sign up for the whole series for
free and get the bonus companion
worksheets that go with each video
check the link in the description below
alright so today is day seven and we're
going to learn how you can develop the
courage you need to win
[Music]
i've learned that courage is not some
deep internal fortitude that you don't
dig down deep and find the courage
you know that courage is external
courage comes from the relationships we
have with those around us
a partner in business a personal
relationship
our team right that's why we want to
build good cultures
because our team believes in us which
gives us courage to do difficult things
um uh so a a a
um a trapeze artist a world famous
trapeze artist
would never try a brand new death
defying act for the very first time
without a net right now all that courage
they
they're they're the world's greatest
trapeze artist but for the they need at
something external before they do
something very dangerous yeah
and it's the same for the rest of us so
when we have someone who says
i believe in you i got your back
even if this doesn't work out i'm here
with you i mentioned
courage and i would i would like to say
something else about that finding
courage in the leaders
and in you who will become leaders
uh courage is the most important
important of all the virtues
because without courage you can't
practice any other virtue
consistently you see you can't be
consistently
kind or fair or
humane or generous
not without courage because if you don't
have it sooner or later you'll stop and
say
ah the threat is too much the
the difficulty is too too high the the
challenge is
is too great when i picked up your book
the thing i loved about it
is the amount of effort that you've been
through to give us i'm sure
this was suffering too like writing this
book the amount of effort that you've
been through to actually give us
detail right on your life we all have
different things in life that have
scarred us
we want to act like those scars don't
exist so those scars like you know if
you go out
and you get cut that scar is going to be
there on your arm you can go down and
look at that cut and say
oh or or that scar and say oh that
happened from
you know i was in the kitchen or what
happened we have the same thing in our
brain
i have all these scars on my brain from
growing up
from you know being abused from
suffering through life from having a
learning disability from stuttering from
having just a really bad childhood and
so all those memories i had to cut open
that scar
and go into it and that was a hard
process for me to do
not only was that a hard process for me
to do for me to have the courage to
share that with people
you know because i'm the so-called
toughest man on the planet
so they think so for me to break open
that shell and tell people hey
that wasn't always me you know it's it's
hard to do you know
it's hard to do so it was a tough
process throughout this journey i
started becoming this new person
i started creating this new person
people started seeing me
as this amazing superhero
in the back of my mind i knew the real
story and i was like man one day you
have to really share it i'm like man but
do you have the courage
you know like it's great to live right
here i've established this people think
you're great
just stay here don't go back let's not
go back
but the only way you can help people out
is let them know that this is possible
so i had to go back and say this is
where i come from
yeah and where i come from is hell
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
what if you could accomplish in the
world today if you weren't afraid
if you weren't afraid of what people
thought of you said about you
whispered about you
what should you accomplish
a lot more than you've accomplished
today a lot more
why do we care what people think why do
we care what people say
and more importantly why do we care what
people whisper
because we have no self-worth we have
next to little
self-esteem and we have no
self-confidence and how do we get that
way
yes mommy and daddy life expands and
contracts with courage
one was the last courage courage
type thing that you did in your lifetime
walk against the red light
whisper that your spouse your
significant other is a [ __ ] or a
bastard
when was the last time you exhibited
some courage
some of you have to go back a long long
way some of you
never i said yesterday i cannot believe
that there are people in this audience
that have never
been spanked never had a harsh word
said to them by their parents never got
in a fight on the school grounds
i can't believe that and you wonder why
you are
the way you are now i'm not saying that
um being a high performance person is
beating
out everybody but it doesn't hurt here's
a stat from
uh from your show and it says the
richest 85 people on this planet
have as much money as the poorest 3.5
billion
yeah right that's on the planet however
in that sense it's not far off in
america
no it isn't far off in america but we
still
and we still here don't abandon the idea
that it isn't finite yeah it isn't
finite if you were
born where were you born me yeah baton
rouge louisiana batteries general
hospital
there you go louisiana i was born in
memphis tennessee
um i had a long haul
uh from where i came from
to here but here we are right
so proof is in the proof of the pudding
and then eating and
here we sit at the dining table but it's
hard to when you say that to some people
because they say oh there you go with it
pull yourself up by the bootstraps thing
and
you know you're just being respectable
not everybody can do that
everybody can
everybody doesn't courage
courage is the key to life itself
there are a lot of people who are born
in situations will survive just i'll
never get out of this
so they won't i say to
people who say well i i would like to
have done so and so and so
some of you could have done it so well i
couldn't get out of here
man the bus runs every day
[Laughter]
you're exactly right yeah you're excited
if they're if they're if you
can conceive it in your mind if you can
think of it you can do it that's a human
condition and we can imagine that we can
do it right
and i think that the the condition of
each individual
human it's not enough to have a great
idea and the focus and the
conscientiousness to see it to fruition
you must have the strength and the
resolve and the courage
to pursue that idea even when the rest
of the world thinks you're insane
right time and time again if you look at
the
stories of extraordinarily uh important
entrepreneurs
there is almost always a moment when
they are the only ones who believe in
the value of what they're doing
you know i tell in my book the story of
my book david and goliath the story of
ingivar comprad the guy who founds ikea
and the crucial moment
in the in the story of ikea is when
he faces a boycott from the other
furniture manufacturers in sweden
and he's about to go out of business and
in desperation
he moves his operations across the
baltic sea from sweden to poland
and sets up shop in poland and that's
what ikea is ikea
is essentially furniture ship flat made
in poland that's the
original elevator pitch for ikea what's
interesting about that is he does it in
1961
at the height of the cold war at a time
when east and west
communist world and free world are
closer to outright war than at any other
time
in history a guy living in the west
sweden
crosses the pond to poland the iron
curtain and sets up shop
you cannot imagine what a controversial
move that was
that's like that would be like walmart
opening operations in north korea
literally it's on that level of kind of
eyebrow raising
you've got to be kidding me who is this
guy kind of thing
but he does it and he persists and he
turns his back on all those critics
why because he is a deeply disagreeable
person
didn't need people to agree with him
right and that's how he's able to build
ikea into this
extraordinary runaway success story
that's
very hard to do as human beings
we are hardwired to want the approval of
our peers
i always tell people what you don't know
can be your greatest asset if you let it
because
it ensures you're going to do it
differently absolutely and when i landed
neiman marcus
all these people came up to me and said
i have been doing this for seven years
ten years five years
how did you land neiman marcus and i
said i called them
and they just looked at me and i was
like why would you do
they're like well i go to trade shows
and i set up my booth and i'm
waiting for the neiman mark aspire to
come by and we've been doing it every
year
for seven years i didn't even know there
were trade shows wow
so sometimes just not knowing how it's
supposed to be done
you have to have the courage though to
say even though i wasn't
trained in this because a lot of people
think well i didn't go to school for
this so
how could i possibly know but you know
it's inside of you
if you actually believe something in a
meeting and it might be against the
grain
saying it in a respectful way matters
because in three years when it becomes
true
the other seven people in that room will
remember that and that may lead to the
growth in your career that you're
looking for
people think they grow in their career
by staying within the framework of their
organization
they're actually quietly subconsciously
ruining their career
if they don't agree with the point of
view and i know for fact
because the best part of can for me
hands down is two three o'clock in the
morning
when people have so much rose in them
they start talking truth
i know for i know for a fact that
there's a lot of people that have
strategies or executions they don't
personally believe in
it's just a framework of where the
margin is in their company or what they
have to be held accountable to a bonus
and that's a tough life in in some way i
mean this is only just work
there's much bigger things going on but
i will say being on the record
in a room respectfully of what you
actually believe brave
is a very very good idea and honestly
back to brave
there's so much content there's so much
going on in the world
what i think this room believes and
defines as brave
is actually the only prayer to break
through consumer attention to make
something happen in your business
after titanic you had so many
interesting career choices
i thought i mean really interesting much
smaller movies they must have come to
you and said do this do that do that and
the choices you made
were really terrific little movies that
are not the obvious choices that you
would make after that kind of a segment
well
you know pete i had to be really brave
yeah you know i did have to be i did
have to be really brave because
it was a moment in time and suddenly
i was offered quite big films i mean
suddenly a lot came my way quite quickly
and i mean i can't even talk about the
size of these paychecks i just
and i just remember thinking i'm not i'm
honestly not ready i don't
i don't i still don't feel like i know
how to do this
yeah i don't know how to act properly i
need to learn
more i can't i can't do it i'm not ready
for that
um and also i wasn't ready to be that
famous i didn't i didn't like that
feeling
yeah i mean honestly i really didn't and
i knew that i wasn't prepared to fuel it
i didn't want to follow suit with
something else that was where nothing
was going to top titanic nothing
and i was just very lucky at the time i
had some
very very good friends around me who
would just say you've got to
you've got to make sure that you you're
doing what is making you happy
and at the same time it was of course
very difficult to be turning down
gigantic films because i was so lucky to
be asked to do them in the first place
and i hadn't auditioned for those i mean
my god i couldn't believe that they just
call you up
come and do it and so it was a it was i
mean it sounds terribly sort of
ungrateful but
i just knew that i needed to look after
my
desire to learn more and and and also i
wasn't i wasn't very experienced i
needed to
be out in the world and and and some of
the films that i was able to do
after titanic like like hideous kinky
holy smoke for example
they took me into the world you know
they took me to morocco into the medina
in marrakech and
you know off into the flinders ranges in
the outback in australia and
you know so i i was living i was living
a a life that
was my life and my choices um and not
something that everyone else was saying
to me are you crazy
what are you what are you you know
you're crazy you're good you've got to
do this and you have to do that
i was like well i'm just i can't i'm not
i'm not ready
wow um yeah and it was quite i had to be
quite
i did have to be quite brave one of the
biggest and most surprising lessons i
learned on this journey was that
i just had this assumption that all
these people i looked up to were
fearless
you know elon musk or bill gates we just
assume they
you know have no fear and how they
achieve what they've done
but what i've learned is that not a
single one of them were fearless
they actually were filled with
tremendous amount of fear
so while they weren't fearless they did
have tremendous amounts of courage
and the difference between fearlessness
and courage is that fearlessness is
jumping off of the cliff without
thinking courage
is acknowledging your fear analyzing the
consequences
and deciding you still care so much
about it you're going to take one step
forward anyway
the very minute that you decide upon
something you know that's what you want
you know you're going to do it all of
these negatives that have been bothering
you
they pick up their baggage and get out
they just move out
they can't live in a positive mind
can you imagine a negative frame of mind
and a positive frame of mind occupying
the same space at the same time could
you imagine that no you can't
because it can't be done and did you
know that the slightest bit of a
a negative metal attitude is sufficient
to destroy the power of prior
did you know that the slightest bit of a
of a negative mental attitude is
sufficient to destroy your plan whatever
it is you're doing
carrying out your definiteness of
purpose you have to move with
courage with faith with determination
in connection with carrying out your
definiteness of purpose i
initially was not trying to do
music at all i mean i came to the united
states my family came and
my parents made that choice my mom um
came over to
miami and her main thing was just like
we don't have money to get you
into college so you're gonna have to get
a scholarship and you're gonna have to
study your butt off
and so that was always my main focus was
just i was like a book nerd i was just
like studying studying studying
so i didn't really think of it as a
plausible thing even though it was
always my escape
you know i would always sneak off into
my room when my parents went to walmart
and i would just like
sing um but yeah i definitely didn't
think of it as a career that was
literally just like
five seconds of bravery that changed my
life where i decided to you know try out
for a show
we asked camila what do you want for
your quinceanera paris
and she told me i want you to go with me
to an audition
what do you do when you're not singing i
would love to say something interesting
but all i do is think karaoke and watch
like one direction videos
if you think your life is complete then
i suggest that you're an ass
because tomorrow always has a great
opportunity in it
your life is not complete until you
close your eyes
so when you say somebody who's in a job
they hate
would love to be able to do this my
comment is why the hell are you in a job
you hate
don't you have the courage to leave it
so you're in a job you hate you're doing
nothing to change it but you'd like
better sometimes i have mouths to feed
sometimes i get it but what were the
things about you not saying what we can
even listen we'd have to go over those
specific cases i think and really get
into each person to break them
but what do you think that were the
things about you one of it is you always
had your eyes open to tomorrow and new
opportunities what were some of the
other things
as part of your personality for because
i've there aren't many people like you
but i've seen
and i'm studying more and more people
where amazing things are happening at 55
and 60
and putting them on life journeys that
they never thought they were going to
have
and i'm and i'm seeing that you guys
have a lot of the similar
attributes but what do you think what
was it about you john
courage courage you know the first time
i went and shot a pilot for bar rescue
was really hard you think it's easy to
scream at people on national television
to insult people on national television
to call you a jerk challenge your
marriage challenge or
challenge your integrity challenge your
professionalism
that's hard that's not who i am i don't
wake up and embarrass people in front of
their friends
right in front of their family bar
rescue is the hardest work i have
ever done the courage that it takes for
me to go out there and do these things
single biggest mistake i've made in my
career was not spending money
it's what put me in a position to be
able to buy real estate
because i had money but i had to buy the
real estate i had to use the money
bradley made a comment the other day
about money
money is not to be saved and hoarded
like like
it's no good if you don't use it this is
the problem with bitcoin
when did when do i transact with it
right i'm sitting on a million dollars
by the bitcoin right now
i can't get rid of it fast enough i
can't go buy stuff with it so until that
that that situation is resolved right
it's why people don't hoard
gold anymore you don't keep gold because
you can't exchange it
money is to be used for those of you out
there that are like complaining about
the cost of anything the truth is that's
what that money's for
the only thing the only purpose money
has
is to be used and and i was scared
that i couldn't produce more money so
every time i spent money i complained
about it
today i'm like that's the biggest
mistake i ever made should have been
spending more money
it wouldn't take taken me 30 years in
the first five years i should have
borrowed money i didn't have
and i should have spent money that i did
have and i should have gone into debt to
do it
to get my brand out there to get it
known the mattress guy in your town did
it
the car guy in your town did it whoever
spent the most money
whoever whoever put it all out there all
the time every day on every tv
radio and the internet wins the battle
it's not the prettiest guy
okay
[Music]
it's not it's the guy that out
advertises that outspent you
it takes courage to make money i think
the courage
uh to be really open about those you
know some of the things i've been
through in the past all comes from
experiencing those things and when i was
going through say you know when i was
going through some of these things
i felt so alone and a lot of girls or
people do
you feel like nobody can understand you
because a lot of these problems deal
with like isolating yourself
and feeling alone and one of the things
that really helped me have the courage
to change
was that i realized that i'm not alone
like there's actually people who
understand me and
there's people who have actually
overcome this and they gave me hope and
so that's why i
really strive to give a positive message
of hope about like
you know if you if you're not happy with
the person you are today i 100
believe that you can change and so
that's what i like to
hopefully share with young girls and i
would say that's what gave me the
courage to
to share nobody has ever achieved
anything big
in business or in any walk of life
without courage of course
whenever you do anything big you do feel
a little scared but you've got to
conquer fear
to discover the hidden hero within you
with courage with self-belief
and the can-do spirit you overcome
any adversity i want to challenge you
with one word
the word that is most important for any
of us to have
it starts with a c i call it the c word
is that big word
courage
all of us need an extra dose of courage
i remember
very clearly and as i think i can still
feel the butterflies in my stomach and
my stomach turning
i was 15 years old i was in england
and they said we are going to show you
how to up sale
it looks so easy from where i was
standing
i said i can ace that until i got to
that high
point on the mountain they put me they
harnessed me up
and they said go all of a sudden
the butterflies show up i have
absolutely no courage every ounce
of i can do it was drained out of me
when i looked down to the bottom and i
was trying to figure out
i have never done this how am i
going to get from the top to the bottom
it started with
putting one foot in front of the others
was i shaking absolutely i even had a
tear coming down my eye
but with some coaching and with a lot of
cheering
i tell you i learned how to abseil
to me courage is not saying that you
don't have fear
it's not saying that you don't have
anxiety
i had to face my fear i had to feel it
and i had to do it anyway and that's
what courage is all about
you ask yourself can i really do this
can i really go back to school can i
really heal
after a broken marriage can i really go
on
we all ask those questions sometimes
especially if we've been through a storm
a financial storm an emotional storm
a relational storm or even a health
storm
when those winds are blowing it seems
as if we're going to capsize in a
sea of fear but hang on for one minute
life is made up of storms
and i've learned from sailing that it
all depends on
how you adjust your
to me riding through the storms getting
courage
starts right here and right here
increase
your courage harden up a little bit take
a cold shower don't always take a warm
shower
acclimate your mind and your body to
doing things
that are harder you know one of my uh
friends who's one of the most successful
people in
young startup but made a billion dollar
evaluation on company of five years
whenever we're talking about new ideas
we're gonna do next if i say
oh that's going to be easy why don't we
do that he says ty there's no money in
what's easy
focus on these intangibles you know the
ability to
have a ton of courage well god wants us
all to be courageous
because he knows we'll face times in
life and situations
and circumstances that it takes more
than just the desire
takes courage many people operate on the
basis of fear
on the basis of what other people think
we as believers should operate on the
basis
of courage courage to say no when we
ought to say no
courage to say yes when we should say
yes
so what kind of courage do you have is
your sort of floating between
depending on the situation or do you
know the difference between
right and wrong for your life and you've
made up your mind
why this project why was it so important
to be a part of it well
they sent me the first um script and uh
i was just enthralled i was like excited
to find out where it went
i thought it was an exciting story that
hasn't been told in this way before
right and uh i thought it was
inspirational about breaking free
about having the courage to do something
against the odds congratulations on the
baby girl
thank you very much if your daughter
sees this what do you want her to take
away from this
i want her to be inspired to know a bit
about american history and know about
where her father's people came from
and um also to uh
be inspired that no matter what
obstacles you face in life
um if you approach it with courage and
conviction
uh you can find a way out of it how do
you get along with other vcs
um so this is funny so
i get along with them very well uh so
there are vcs that are
that i really really like um anil buzuri
is one of them who i work with all the
time on
on various deals i just uh i just got
off the phone with ted schlein who i get
along with very very well
so there are a lot of there are a lot of
vcs i get along with i'm a bad cultural
fit for investing
you may have noticed uh and and
there's a good reason for this so
investor
if you think about uh the investing
environment it's this weird co-op
petition thing because you compete for
deals but you work on deals together so
your kind of partners but your
competitors
and i don't come from that culture i
come from enterprise software
right like you know who the top dog in
enterprise software is larry ellison
right like ain't no co-optician in larry
ellison
right like all you have to do is mention
like anybody who's close to a competitor
and it's like his head will blow off
like and he'll go like bananas like
speaking of a neil we saw that it deep
yeah he just went absolutely bananas
it's like it's on baby
it's like you stepped up my shoes
let's go um and so you know
you know for me and then you know also i
listen to little weezy
[Laughter]
and so sometimes you know the venture
capitalists will come at me you know
being friendly hey you know with the
peace sign and you know to me the peace
sign is just the trigger and the middle
finger you know
so that's a name
that's from wheezy does it
does it bother you when they talk [ __ ]
about you because they don't do it to
your face they do it to people like me
anonymous
so yeah so that was a and you're
alluding a little bit to when i called
them
crybabies which gets actually another
thing the one thing that does bother me
a little bit about
some vcs and some angels so one of the
things that's happened a lot since we've
been in the industry is
we get a lot of people calling the press
anonymously there are probably more
anonymous quotes about us in the press
than any other
like entity right now and sarah calls me
up and she goes
ben i got a tip from six different
anonymous angels saying that you're
doing this
and i'm going if they don't like what
i'm doing
why don't they just come out and say it
you know like if i don't like something
somebody's doing i just come out so i
put my name on it
and the reason that bothers me so much
is the number one thing we look for in
an entrepreneur and the number one thing
that i encourage
and i try and help people develop is
courage
and the reason that that's important and
it's very very important and it goes
back to aristotle
so aristotle said courage is the first
virtue
and the reason it's the first virtue is
if you don't have it
then you don't have any virtue because
all these other things honesty integrity
you know whatever don't ever get
activated if in when they're important
if you don't have cards it's easy to be
honest
unless it's going to cost you your job
or your marriage
or something you care about then it's
hard to be honest
so without courage like you don't have
anything you don't have integrity you
don't have anything you're you're just
like the you're a zero character person
and so when people who are supposed to
be coaching entrepreneurs
angel investors or vcs walk around
giving anonymous tips
to like reporters about stuff they don't
think is right
like and those guys are advising the
people who i'm working with like that
really like
you know that that's something that like
pissed me off um
so like i'm not having it and like i'mma
call them on it and like they come at me
again
you anonymous quote me i can't wait to
get it
tomorrow now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the best
life 30 questions of the day
now it's not enough to just watch a
video you have to
do something take action so pull out
your worksheets and let's get to work
and if you don't have the worksheets for
this video check the link in the
description to get them for free
question number one where do you need to
have more courage
number two how can you just take your
shot
today and number three how can you build
courage into your daily routine
and if you're doing the best life 30
challenge with me give me a hashtag
bestlife30 in the comments below so we
could celebrate with you
your story is the secret to finding your
purpose
the thing that you feel is holding you
back and that you're afraid of
is actually the thing that you need to
lean into so that you can help
other people your purpose in life comes
from your pain
and you can either succumb to that pain
and let it control you for
life or you can use that pain to change
the world
so my biggest pain was being an
entrepreneur and struggling and
suffering and making 300
a month and only thirty percent of the
company and turning down
extremely high paying jobs to go off and
be an entrepreneur and live the
entrepreneur life
and i was too embarrassed and a shame to
tell my friends that i was struggling
and suffering and not making any money
and i hated myself and i felt like a
loser i felt like
i was adding no value i felt like i was
getting up
every day and working and working and
working the entire day and not seeing my
friends
and not doing any other stuff that i
wanted to do because i was so focused on
building my business and i wasn't
getting results
like nothing was happening every single
day
and i was tired of living way below the
poverty line and i told my business
partner that i quit
and that was the worst day of my life
that one day when i decided that i quit
eventually i woke up the next day and i
said i can't quit i'd rather no one
failed did not know and
i'd ask myself who else had done this
before who else had built a software
company how can i learn from
that person model their success to build
my own company up
but i love helping entrepreneurs now
because i struggled so much as an
entrepreneur that was my
pain if you want to join the best life
30 challenge click the link right here
below me or if you want even more videos
on how to build your courage
check out the playlist right there next
to me continue to believe and i'll see
you soon